last week I told you that a Supreme
Court decision has mandated that yes
Pennsylvania has to redraw its
congressional districts
Pennsylvania's congressional districts
have been so gerrymandered since the
2010 census and the 2011 redistricting
that took place that even though you
have eight hundred eight hundred
thousand more Democrats than Republicans
in passed of Pennsylvania Republicans
have controlled about two-thirds of the
18 congressional district for a long
time well they did it Pennsylvania
Republicans drew brand-new congressional
districts and they are basically just as
gerrymandered as before we have a map of
the new districts overlaid above the
county level results from the 2016
election and what you'll notice if
you're looking at the map is that the
bluer areas are strategically drawn into
districts to achieve the exact same
thing as before which is that even
though Republicans that are at a deficit
in terms of voters in Pennsylvania they
hold advantage in a majority of
districts and there was an interesting
analysis done by the it was either the
Washington Post or the New York Times
where what they did is they sort of
looked at how the districts were drawn
in 2016 when Trump won 12 of 18
districts and then they Rita Buell ated
the 2016 presidential election results
based on the new drawing of the
districts Trump would have also won 12
districts with the new drawing which
tells us that this is still just as
gerrymandered now in the interest of
sort of being fair right we know that
because Democratic voters tend to be
more in urban areas and Republican
voters tend to be more in rural areas
that does create some base level of
advantage for Republicans at the
congressional district level but not
winning 2/3 of all districts three
elections in a row
despite being at a significant
disadvantage in terms of the number of
registered Republicans so this is
obviously completely ridiculous they
they are
claiming the Republicans are claiming no
we redrew the districts without partisan
data in hand that's the stupidest excuse
I've ever heard if you're familiar with
the state's politics and the
geographical distribution of voters you
don't need a partisan list in order to
draw a partisan map and now we'll have
to see ultimately what the Democratic
governor of Pennsylvania decides and
this is why I've been saying we've got a
vote because now that these new
districts are going to be challenged
legally the Democratic governor of
Pennsylvania gets to look at it and say
yes or no and if he says no then a
nonpartisan redistricting an expert in
drawing districts is going to take over
this is why it matters whether the
governor is a Republican or a Democrat
this is why it matters if the state
Senate or the state legislature has a
majority of Republicans or Democrats and
this is why I've been talking about the
importance of the census for years even
though these are not as I've said before
the most exciting topics to discuss this
stuff has such an impact and we do need
an independent commission because
whenever Republicans are in control of
the state legislature they draw the
lines in favor of their party you have
Democrats whenever they're in charge of
the state legislature that's right they
draw the lines in control of their party
- and so if we had just representatives
from both parties or unbiased arbiters
who are able to draw these maps yeah it
would turn out a lot better or maybe
even put it in the in the control of the
courts they're used to being unbiased
there's a bunch of different ways you
can do it they're a bipartisan
Commission some kind of uninvolved
nonpartisan agency courts basically any
option is better than what's being done
no it's just just a perfect no system
will be perfect but we know that one of
the worst systems is letting whoever
happen to win the last election after
the last census putting them in charge
of destroying the districts how they
want that's what leads to the disasters
that we've seen I mean it's happened in
Massachusetts it's happened in Illinois
there's a lot of places with just wacky
and crazy districts and it took the US
Supreme Court seven years to throw out
the first Pennsylvania map that's right
they can't wait another seven we only
have another three years left before the
next census that's right
the the the time that it takes to fix
these problems is absolutely
unconscionable the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad